I want you to think about the teacher that
you still today remember.
Think about that one teacher.
We all got one of them, minimum, that we remember,
right?
Today I'm going to share with you how you
can be that teacher to many people in business
or in life.
Because in reality, as an entrepreneur, one
of the things you'll do a lot is teaching.
You'll teach your clients.
You'll teach your vendors.
You'll teach your partners about your company,
and investors.
You'll teach your salespeople, you'll teach
everybody about who you are and what you do.
And the better you are at teaching, the better
your business is going to do, and the more
you're going to grow because everyone's learning
how to take the stuff that you know in here
and implement it.
So let's get right into it.
Step #1: Whatever you're teaching, sell what
you're teaching.
Let me explain.
If you're teaching me math, sell me the importance
of wanting to learn math.
Sell me.
Sell it to me.
Here's why math is so important!
It's so exciting.
And everything in life is math because if
you look at everything, it's angles and sports
is math and everything is math.
Sell it to me.
Sell me whatever you're teaching, is step
#1.
#2.
If you can find a way to add fun, humor and
creativity to it, what you do is this.
This is what happens.
Think about the mind being close-minded.
So the mind is closed.
Every time you use fun, humor, or creativity,
it opens up my mind.
Just think about visually I have a hole here.
When it opens up my mind, I'm willing to have
information enter my mind.
Great teachers know how to have fun, humor,
creativity open up the mind so they're willing
to be sold on whatever you're teaching to
them.
And if, IF, you know how to add sticky stories
to whatever you're teaching, using some sort
of fun, humor and creativity, it sticks forever.
People will tell those stories forever and
they'll remember whatever you're teaching
them, based on the story you told because
when they go home at night, you know what
they're going to tell them?
Hey, honey, you won't believe what I learned
today.
What did you learn?
Did you know that in 1976 Steve Jobs. . . and
because of that, this is how the PC came out
and the mouse and.
. . No way, babe!
You just sold them why they need to learn
this, you added fun, humor and creativity,
you had a sticky story.
It stuck, they went and taught their wife
and their three kids that night - you're a
great teacher.
#3, Simplify.
Make it look easy.
Whatever you're doing, make it look easy.
Don't complicate things.
Make it look very easy.
#4, Give them steps.
First you do this, then you do that then you
do this.
Give them simple steps to follow that if they
do, they can do what you're teaching them
to do.
#5: Sell belief.
This is easy.
You can do it.
It's not that hard.
Sell them the belief.
You can pull this off, right?
So if I'm teaching how to shoot a basketball,
step #1, bend your knees.
Two, boom, this is three, it's easy.
You can do it.
Let's do it again.
Next, teach the way they learn.
Some learn visually, some learn through reading,
some learn through listening.
Some learn through hands on.
Teach so many different ways that you can
pretty much teach all the different audiences
on the way that they learn, whatever you are
trying to teach them.
Next, re-remind.
This is typically the biggest mistake teachers
make is because they forget to re-remind,
and re-remind.
They say, "Don't you already get it?
Haven't I already told you?
I already told you this!"
So for me when I go home every night, I ask
both of my sons, "What are the four things
we focus on as a family.
That we lead, love, respect, improve.
Do we bully?
No.
Do we get bullied?
No."
I've probably asked them this two, three hundred
times.
Do you know why?
Because teaching is about re-reminding.
Not just saying it one time and they remember.
It's about reminding.
Think about it like a commercial.
Toyota does the same commercial, same commercial,
same commercial, same commercial, and then
you say it.
Guinness, you know the drink, does the same
commercial, same commercial, same commercial,
and then you say it.
Re-remind.
You're like a commercial you're doing to teach
people.
Next, be patient.
Why?
Because the speed of learning varies for everybody.
Some learn fast.
Some don't learn fast.
And sometimes the best students end up being
the ones that don't learn fast.
So can you imagine if you go all in, just
with the guy that learns very fast, but he's
lazy, then you got a guy here that takes him
six months to learn, but he's the hardest
working guy you got.
You got to make sure you vary, based on what
speed learning they learn.
And last but not least, be a great student.
If you're a great student, typically the greatest
teachers make the greatest students.
I don't know why that is, because you're so
curious yourself, you're always learning.
People want to learn from you because this
thing's always growing.
And people are excited about that and it's
like, man, this is so cool.
If it's this exciting to learn, I want to
learn.
If my teacher's always learning, what if I
learn like he learns.
What if I learn like she learns?
Man, I want to learn some more.
So you got to be a great student in order
for you to be a great teacher.
And last but not least, last but not least.
Every time if you want your students to be
wanting to learn more and more and more, you
got to make sure you encourage them, you praise
them, you recognize them.
For instance.
There you go, buddy, you got it down.
Good job!
You made that shot.
Awesome job, buddy!
That's exactly how you write that sentence.
That's exactly how that works!
You praise in front of people.
Did you guys see what Bobby did?
Great job, Bobby!
Then you recognize them.
The best, top three best students right now,
I just want to say, Bobby, because of this,
I got this gift for you.
Boom.
You did this.
You recognize, praise, you encourage.
And eventually, people want to learn more
because you become the teacher that everybody
remembers forever and ever and ever to come,
and when I ask somebody in the future, hey,
who is the one teacher you will never forget?
And they say your name.
I'm talking to you.
They say your name because all this stuff
I just covered with you, you can learn.
So with that being said, Paul, this is the
shortest episode we've done in a while, with
our new pillow we got here, from Jennifer
Mac!
Much love to Jennifer Mac.
Hey, you got questions, comments about what
I just shot here, post it on the bottom.
If you want to send me a question about what
I said here, you can always snap me, the snap
thing is right over here, betdavid19.
Send me a video.
It's a lot easier for me to respond back.
And if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
what are you waiting for?
Join the club of 170-some thousand people
that have already subscribed to the number
one channel on YouTube for how to for entrepreneurs,
click this button here to subscribe.
And click the notification right next to it
and you become one of the first to be notified
whenever a new video goes out.
Because we have a goal of a million subs,
by the end of 2017.
And we need your help to help us get there.
Good catch, Pauley.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Take care, bye bye.